du cinéma pour terminer avec le dernier
film de nikita mikhalkov soleil trompeur
un film qui avait obtenu le grand prix
du jury au festival de cannes le
réalisateur russe revient sur la terreur
dans l'union soviétique des années 30
sous staline
il raconte et ils interprètent 24 heures
de la vie d'une famille nicole cornu
langlois et andreï sort pas pourquoi tu
as fait ce film soleil trompeur le
manière générale le soleil trompeur
c'est l'image de cette boule de feu
c'est le buzz chez eux dans toutes ses
formes
il ne change que de couleurs civisme de
1917 différencie en rien dû mieux le
chimiste de 1994 alors pour que nadia sa
fille ne connaissent pas le soleil
trompeur
nikita fait revivre une journée
insouciante dans une datcha de 1936 il
est le colonel kotov héros de la
révolution qui joue de son prestige pour
défier l'absurdité de la bureaucratie
mais sous les traits d'un ami
imperceptiblement la traîtrise la
violence arrivent jusqu'à la tragédie
regarde tout nié tout est beau voilà
c'est ali le parti en a tous on a une
belle vie tout est beau un nom savant
d'accord ça oui évidemment mais c'est
pas très important mais oui je sais mais
pas moi pas moi non avec moi ça peut
jamais marché non mais avec lui oui bah
oui évidemment ah oui je pensais qu'il
était honnête en fait non c'est pas le
plus fort mais avec moi c'est pas
possible que ça non et voilà c'est
tchekhov soustelle
delgado pourquoi voulez vous que je
tourne sur ce film moi qui t'ai choisi
c'est dieu qui lui a donné un mois car
ce film superbe n'est pas seulement une
mise en garde
c'est aussi la déclaration d'amour d'un
père à sa fille